[Musik]
abgebrochen mit präsenzunterricht sich
auf der suche nach einer möglichkeit
auch in ruhe der anzug
[Musik]
das angebot finde ich super
man hat die möglichkeit kurzfristig auch
für einige tage nur einen ruhigen raum
oder ruhigen ort zum lernen oder zum
arbeiten zu finden und auch tagsüber
entsprechend sich voll und ganz auf die
arbeit zu konzentrieren also die home
office zimmer im hotel als hotel office
zu vermieten ist eine möglichkeit um an
etwas geld zu kommen aber es reicht
nicht um die kompletten kosten zu decken
also es ist eine möglichkeit um alles
ausgeschöpft
damit man auch sagen kann ich habe alles
versucht um über die krise zu kommen
aber die mitarbeiter müssen trotzdem in
kurzarbeit
zumindest die meisten einige wir haben
ja auch einige zimmer wo leuten immer
noch arbeiten monteure oder
geschäftsleute und die zimmer vermieten
wir natürlich auch aber es reicht bei
weitem nicht um komplett die kosten zu
decken